MATCH-UP.
>>
PICKED UP BY MANSON WHO REVERSES
IT BEHIND THE NET, LATER60%. I'E
NOTICED HERE ABOUT JACK CAMPBELL
HERE IN EARLY KAMPF IN THE CORN
BENOIT, RICHIE GETS IT BA CAN T
TRAILER RAKELL, ZEGRAS FIRES AND
MAKES ITS WAY TO CAMPBELLILL TH
ANAHEIM ZONE.
FOWLER DOESN'T WANT JUST A TERR
PASS THAT SPRINGS HIM FOR A --
LOOK. AT MARNER, MIDDLE OF YOUR
SCREEN AT THE BOTTOM. SOME OFFE
THIS ONEGETS THAT PUCK, AND WAT
PULL THIS TO THE BACKHAND AND
I'VE GOT TO BELIEVE HE'S
TH MANSON
WIRES ONE OFF THE STICK OF
CAMPBELL AND OUT OF PLAY.
>> Brian: I THINK IT'S OFF THE
SHAF GETZLAF HAD IT
IN HIS EQUIPMENT, GETS IT DOWN
ANDM WAS SAM STEEL. CAMPBELL'S
BEEN GOOD BUT NO REBOUND OPENIN.
RICHIE ANGLES IT BACK.
FIRST TIME NICK HAS COME BACK
SINCE THE DUCKS TRADED
MISCOMMUNICATION AS SPEZZA
PLAYED IT BACK TO THE POINT AND
NOBODY WAS HOME SO SANDIN AND
NOW THE TOP UNIT OUT WITH 45
SECONDS LEFT.
MARNER SHAKES OFF A COUPLE
DEFENDERS IN THE NEUTRAL ZONE P
CLIFFORD BEATEN TO THE PUCK LEA
30 GOALS OR MORE IN EACH OF HIS
FIRST FIVE SEASONS.
41 LAST YEAR, AND ONE MORE  WITE
CENTER LOGO BUT DROPS
NET, LIN
SCORES!
HAMPUS LINDHOLM IN HIS USUAL
SPOT RIGHT AT THE TOP OF THE
GOAL CREOAL, CLIFFORD
KEEPS IT ALIVE ON THE LEFT
BOARDS.
SPEZZA PUTS IT BEHIND THE NET
AND ENGVALL RUN OFF F  6:50 TO
PLAY.
FACE-OFF IN THE ANAHEIM ZONE
CONTROROTHERE BY MATTHEWS, THEY.
MARNER FINDS MATTHE ARIZONA COY
HE'S FOUND APRIL HOME HERE.
>> John: FIFTH AMONG ROOKIES IN
GOALS AND POINTS.
THAT WAS HIS SIXTH GOAL OF THE
SEASON.
HE'S GOT POINTS NOW, DOES
BUNTING, IN FOUR STRAIGHT GAMES.
ZEGRAS FOR THE DUCKS STORMS IN
ON RIGHT WING AND 0-GOAL SCORER
MAKING IT 4-1. 5-1.
>> Brian: YEAH.
AND THESE ARE THE GOALS THAT
DRIVE GOALTENDERS